en 10e position les plus infidèles sont
les Clémence
en 9 Vanessa
en 8 Juliette
en cette Alice ok
[Rires]
donc ici vous êtes toutes fidèle bravo
bravo
et enfin les garçons en 10 Maxime
en 9 Didier
Geoffrey en 6 Alexandre
en quatre pierres
en trois Jean-Marie
en deux Guillaume non pas du tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est d'accord
faut pas tromper non faut partir
blouson
faut partir faut pas tromper
tu vas continuer sans arrêt trompé mais
non arrête arrête
la vérité mais je vous dis la vérité
stop
c'est l'homme de ma vie donc il est hors
de question enfin voilà
quand j'étais jeune je pouvais être avec
quelqu'un et je le tromper le seul quoi
c'est toi ici
et toi tu es là tu poses pas les bonnes
questions